yo i hate man that when you fill out
your your year mm-hmm you felt your but
your date of birth sometimes in japan
they want to know the era you were born
in yeah yeah oh yeah yeah you were born
the era yeah yeah it's like do you
remember your era
hi haywin
i think i am i think so
you guys are speaking a different
language right now i have no [ __ ]
you're probably like hey say two what
you want
1919 this is stupid
you got to circle the [ __ ] kanji
you're born it's like it's like why
it sounds like astrology with extra
steps
it's like it's like it's like having
shots
hey sagittarius
yes so it's like it's like if you go
today to birth it's like so called the
queen or king the reigning monarch
circle the the picture of that well you
wouldn't have a problem with that
because
uh which one but it's just like i don't
get it because some some government ones
don't do it some governments do do it
can you all just decide why can't we use
the numerix it's easy everyone likes
numerix yeah what i don't understand is
how how universally so you we have we
have the date right i believe it's on
the by
uh you know we have the day the month
and the year
now what order does that go in listen
okay it depends on the country
what are you in australia
day month no month day year oh you do
american style no no day month year so
wait what [ __ ] i don't even know anymore
wait what are we doing how do we do it
here japan does japan just year month
day which i think actually makes the
most sense yeah right i disagree why why
because where are you right now you're
in the day you're in the day and then
you're in the month and then you're in
the air okay you try you try you try it
okay you know how japanese documents
yeah now try sorting documents out in
your mind how do you sort them by
by day
you go you go by yeah with the year you
go by the year first right and that's
how i know japan chose to put the year
first because if you put it into like
putting putting sorting documents in the
computer you're like yeah like you start
you start off the file name with the
year it source out perfectly you start
it off you start off the file name with
the day
it's a [ __ ]
time where
give me all the documents that were
signed on the 11th
of any month and every year
just the 11. it's like you're um you
know your i don't know how americans do
your address but you do your address
right you do you do your street first
and your number of the apartment you get
bigger and bigger right so yeah you you
ascend into
uh the scale right let's say i'm in
australia i think right you do your your
address of your house like the number
the street and then you do the
county or whatever then other town
county council countries yeah
japan is like the other way around isn't
it yeah it's the other way yeah you
start with the prefecture and then yeah
the city yeah and then the area of the
prefecture and then the block of those
yeah yeah yeah i think that makes more
sense though because like you're
narrowing it down as you're searching
for this address right yeah
yeah but
the way i see it is that like if you're
in a postal system you're gonna like the
first thing you're gonna read is the
first line right so i think like if you
look at something you're always gonna
look at the first line if i manage
delivering letters i'm going to be
working in like [ __ ] hokkaido anyway
right i don't even know that i'm working
in hokkaido these letters are all
hokkaido like i'm just going to look at
the number all right here we go
i guess on on the flip side though but i
think we can both agree what what why
why americans why'd you put the month
first yeah
why why that is weird well this is what
i mean
like trash taste we we get confused with
everything the one thing we agree on
[ __ ] on america
i love america what's going on
does that make sense you know why would
you put the month first over the day or
the year because it always [ __ ] me up
when i buy a new pc and it tells me like
it i set the date and it's always like
the month first what if it's like
the 11th of the 11th right yeah like
it's i'm sometimes i'm literally
confused as to
what the uh what the format is because
like the day isn't large enough to
dictate if it's a month or a day and at
the same time
they do that and yet they call it 4th of
july
not july 4th
so i'm like i never thought about that i
never thought about that so i'm like why
would you not call it july 4th i think
some people call it your life fourth but
i think i've never i don't know how to
get your life everyone's called a fourth
of july yeah
yeah
july 4th sounds like it feels dirty
it doesn't seem to be even american
maybe there's some reason why but just
from a from a just a normal zero
understanding of uh background like it
does make seem to make no sense for the
month yes then the day because you're
not even doing in some order you're just
like
you're just like shuffling it yeah
like putting the year second that feels
like something america would do it's
like
it's like
the 11th of 1994
october
may as well you've already chose anarchy
i know there's a reason why there's
probably a reason why i'm just too dumb
done i'm sure he just wanted to be
different
i feel like that's a lot of like there's
a lot of things with america like the
imperial imperial versus metric system
yeah you know it's just like there are
just some things where
decided okay this is the way we're going
to okay okay but you have to admit
i think the uk i don't know about
australia but i think uk is the worst oh
no uk the uk is [ __ ] awful as well
because we mix like what are you doing
the absolute state of this country no we
no in australia it's all matrix yeah
it's the only time like actually the
only time in australia where we would
ever use the imperial system is when
we're talking about like
basketball players like every time i
[ __ ] on the american imperial system
they're like what's miles per hour
and i'm like i would like to retract my
statements
my country is just as stupid i refuse
to use the imperial system i will not
use it i i will go out of my way to
avoid using it because it's so
inconsistent yeah i just think that i
think that the more you just kind of
like i don't know i want to be like all
right i'm not i'm not going to change
this i'm i'm i'm one man i can't change
yeah yeah but i'm like if i just
if i have my way and other people adopt
it too maybe things will change
eventually i like it i left the country
so maybe not
but you know to me it's like but i like
the metric system because it's like it
works in increments of tens yeah it's
like ten a hundred a thousand meanwhile
in america it's like uh three inches to
the yard uh
god knows how many no three inches of
the foot i think it's what like sixteen
four teddy
oh this land looks like it's about
penguin flops large yes four penguin
flops large it seems to be no i mean
okay the uk is the his wife right
because in america at least they've
decided that pounds is a system they're
going to use to measure weight right
yeah in the uk we decided no no no we
need pounds and stones
yeah and it's like this is the dumbest
[ __ ] ever and it's the reason why i hate
watching like weight loss tv shows in
the uk because they just hit me with
these [ __ ] metrics that i can't
understand yeah they're like tim was 12
stone 18 pounds no that doesn't make
sense
tim was 12 stones and 12 pounds he's now
down to 11 so what does that mean i
don't know how many pounds to a stone
no no it's like 14 i think is it is he
sure all i know is losing a stone of
weight is an impressive feat that's just
that's just what i know i don't know how
many pounds to a stone this is 16 i
swear it's not 16.
here's the question there okay how much
is a pound
because in my head it makes no [ __ ]
sense because for us it's kilograms and
grams the only time i ever get a frame
of reference is when i go to the gym and
both the machines have the kilogram and
the pounds and then i'm kind of like i'm
like oh just a little bit of studying
trying to figure it out
yeah because like because every time
like an american comes up to me it's
like oh man i'm so fat i'm like 130
pounds i'm like
that that's not fat that's that's good i
don't it seems a lot to me you're just
you're just spouting out numbers yeah
130 seems a lot in my world yeah yeah
it's weird as well because like you know
because i'm under six foot i want to
abolish the whole six foot let's go to
centimeters that sounds good right like
let's go to that i mean i i never used i
never used
until i started dating hockey
because i told her i'm like how old uh
how tall are you and she's like oh i'm
like five foot i'm like that means
nothing to me i i didn't i didn't start
using feet until everyone on the
internet started using feet yeah yeah
and i i didn't know yeah why do people
on the internet use feet
it's it's just something that you
universally no one says their height in
centimeters on the internet even though
a lot of the world still use centimeters
because every time you do there's going
to be at least one american in the reply
being like um can you use the imperial
system please so i've had to i i
literally did not know
what how tall i was in fee until i went
on the internet yeah i'm just like this
is part of the internet it's learning
you're hiding foot apparently
and then like okay so when you when you
cook right if you get a cooking book
from 40 years ago in the uk it'll all be
in ounces if you get a cookbook now in
the uk it'll be in grams and liters
right what yeah
weird right so that's not an issue
because uh
none of us cook
what i'm saying
i agree i agree but what i'm saying is
the consistency is [ __ ] annoying yeah
like nobody said whenever you use the
cookbook connor when i tried to cook it
didn't work out because i couldn't
follow the two because i didn't know
what an ounce was right do you have like
a
what's it called like i don't even know
what's it called like a measuring weight
thing like this
like a kitchen scale yeah okay scale
that's what i was talking about god
tries to prove he's not a drug dealer um
yeah [ __ ] off i have kitchen skills yeah
yeah you you have kitchen skills because
arki cooks like yeah
it seems like a good thing to have i
don't know sometimes it comes in useful
have you ever used it yeah not for
cooking not to pack my drawer
[Music]
sometimes there's things that like i
want to measure something that is not
heavy enough to put on my actual scales
likewise it won't i don't know just like
maybe it's uh i don't know certain
powder
like what what are you measuring
things i can't remember what though
um yeah so it's really annoying that
it's inconsistent with the that we
changed randomly nobody nobody said that
we had to change the grams and liters
for cooking we just did yeah but then we
didn't change miles because all the
signs are in miles so that's not going
to yeah i've always wondered why do you
guys still measure it in miles per hour
no idea because you know because you do
you measure distance in miles we do
actually yeah really yeah so it's really
confusing because i remember that we
it's it's really strange because we're
in the eu and we were for a long time
but then we refused to do anything and
if you go to any of these countries it's
all in kilometers yeah sometimes some
countries um it's it's a mess it's such
a mess yeah and although if you learn
science or anything in the uk you learn
the sr units which is all which
obviously or kelvin and uh
yeah but that's the same in america as
well they they teach you not always
sometimes they do really yeah some some
i don't know if you mean the sciences i
don't know if they still do it but some
places do because some okay because when
i i was in university as well i was
doing engineering some of the older
papers they gave me did you have this
yeah some of them were like can you
figure it out in pounds per inch like
force oh
yeah yeah and that was all questions
yeah and i i was just like
yeah
and i'm like this formula is complicated
enough as it is and you want me to
convert that into pounds to inches
every time i heard pounds per square
inch in mythbusters episodes i was like
i'm just gonna give up yeah
i don't know if they do in america i
totally did oh are you behind it i don't
think your hand is up can you can you
check if they still teach in america and
universities um
i just know there's a famous case where
yeah the nasa yeah yeah oh yeah yeah the
the hubble space telescope right right
uh oh no no no it was it was a mars
mission it was a mars mission it was
like a [ __ ] billion dollar mission or
something and it got [ __ ] up uh and
burned up in the mars atmosphere yeah
because
the teams designing it couldn't agree on
whether they were using imperial units
or metrics i think they think they're
just miscoordinating yeah they
mis-coordinated yeah yeah all right so
that's you know probably the most
expensive fuck-up to do with
uh today with the measuring system
i don't know if you go to if you go to a
pool flat earth is celebrating right now
if you if you go to a pool in the uk oh
it's a 25 minute pool yeah it's oh it's
two meters deep yeah oh how far is the
journey to the the two meter pool oh
it's one mile away it's like it's like
can we just [ __ ] decide
like it's it's it's like we've made this
weird [ __ ] system where we just can't
[ __ ] decide what's going to be used
where yeah and it's totally up to
whoever is the governing body of that
thing that they decide and then that's
the thing but nobody seems to have an
issue with all these these these metric
and imperial units mixing and then there
was a thing in the uk recently and i'm
pretty sure it was just outrage bait to
like get people to be outraged about
something that wasn't like super shady
they were trying to get attention off it
was like we're going to bring back the
imperial units and everyone's like but
why
why would we do that yeah but then we
use celsius we don't use fahrenheit so
we don't use that yeah so it's like it's
like okay can we just [ __ ] decide
that's also another thing i just can't
stand every time i got home okay to be
honest the one thing that pisses me off
the most of any unit and is the most
frustrating unit
is ounces in america because
they're different because it's american
fluid ounces and and ounces so the bag
of doritos is a 16-ounce bag or
something yeah
what does that mean
this is like magic to me i genuinely
don't under this is genuinely like a
runescape question i can't figure this
[ __ ] out it might as well be an alvin
i don't know
you got two uh two engineers here and uh
and uh
i can't [ __ ] figure it out i barely
have some semblance of what an ounce is
i can roughly figure out what announces
what yeah i have fluid i have no [ __ ]
clue what i don't even know
out of shape that's what i am oh you
might you must have measured yourself
when you did the uh
the uh thingy test right the uh medical
test oh like a year ago yes things
changed
oh it's creeping up we we've got our
next medical test i was like
76 kilograms i think can i last
i'm probably not that anymore but
i don't know how what i don't know what
that is in pounds or ounces
not different bro built differently i
have no way the thing is now now i know
my height and feet more than like more
than i remember in centimeters
i'm like i think i'm
182 or three centimeters but i'm not 100
sure just because just because i haven't
said it in so long well you are taller
than me slightly and i'm 181 so that
makes sense okay yeah so i have to be
more than one centimeter taller than you
right probably so you're probably 183
okay 176 or something 176. look at that
you're not that short i know that one's
shorter look at this guy under 180.
imagine being below six feet
imagine being below 100. i don't even
know if 181 is six feet or nothing
i'm pretty sure it is i think it is
right yeah it's like just six feet yeah
yeah who knows i don't even know
it's weird